[Music]
years ago I was sitting in Financial
Peace University classes and people said
what I'll do first and what do I do
after that and what do I do after that
where do I start
in my situation what do I do and out of
those conversations we started realizing
we all need a good financial planning
clear path a clear path to go from where
ever I am to wealthy that's financial
planning if you don't want to do that
that's okay you probably shouldn't
listen to the show it's what we're doing
all the time here we're trying to take
you from wherever you are to wealthy
wealthy and stable for that matter not
only getting out of debt but there's a
reason to get out of that you get out of
debt so that you can retire with dignity
you get out of debt so that you can
change your family tree you get out of
debt so that you can build wealth and be
outrageously generous so the baby steps
was developed out of that I didn't just
sit around one day on my couch and go we
need 7 baby steps in the financial space
and I think I'll invent them now it's
actually I had worked with thousands and
thousands and thousands of people and I
couldn't answer their question without
digging into each and every situation
going this is what you do this is what
you do this is what you do but we know
you need to be out of debt and have an
emergency fund that's foundational any
of us in the financial planning arena
know that it's foundational and we know
you need to be investing to be able to
build wealth that's foundational and we
know your mortgage is big so paying that
off it's foundational this so just the
question was how to put those in an
order that was practical and applicable
that actually worked and that's where
the baby steps were born and you know
the reason that they've been so
successful why the book the Total Money
Makeover which is basically the baby
steps on steroids why it's been so
successful is because it's clear path
and it's based on basic financial
planning logic
and it works and so even my friends in
the financial planning community that
don't like me grudgingly admit that the
baby steps is freakin genius and because
it is it is not because I'm genius but
because it's a clear path and we all
need a clear path to do whatever it is
we're gonna succeed at what are the
things I need to do to get to winning if
I'm not winning
what's the steps what's the clear path
we all need that so to get you started
on the right foot we have the baby steps
bundle in the store right now which
includes the Total Money Makeover and
includes the retire inspired audio book
the love your life not theirs audiobook
the starter envelope system the every
dollar guide to budgeting and you get a
free pass to the smart money live stream
experience that Chris Hogan and I will
be doing in Louisville Kentucky on April
the 25th you can watch that event
livestream as a part of this this is a
limited time offer you can get all that
for $29.99 that is a deal Dave Ramsey
comm or call us a triple a 22-piece
triple 8 2 to 7 3 2 to 3 but the moral
of this story is not the bundle the
moral of the story is develop a clear
path to something find someone that has
a clear path to it you want to lose
weight what's the clear path to losing
weight you want to improve your marriage
what's the clear path to improving your
marriage what do you do whatever you
know do this and then find a proven
process a proven plan and then don't try
to fix it because if you already had it
figured out you'd already be there so
don't fix somebody else's clear path
somebody else's process it's already
working
don't I mean have you ever had anything
more aggravating than you know a friend
of yours asked you to lunch and says hey
I'm having trouble my marriage where you
think and then you
tell them and they don't do any of it
and yet you've got a great marriage and
theirs is on the rocks and you go dude
you know the way you talked to her no
wonder you know you treat her like dirt
man I mean what's your deal and then you
don't change you know nothing worse than
giving somebody advice and they don't
change doesn't doing good it's wasting
my time I've had friends and relatives
over the years to say I want your
opinion about this and then they go do
none of it so the next time they want to
take up my time for my opinion about
something I'm not as available you know
I'm saying so when you find something
that works submit yourself to it submit
yourself to it I have a friend of mine
that is only a weight loss exercise
program that is dialed in and she has
lost 65 pounds and is in great shape you
know she did she did not try to fix any
of their system she's not trying to
modify and do her version of any of
their system
she found their system it absolutely
works and she's doing every iota of it
she completely bought in join the cult
shave your head and drink the kool-aid
right submit yourself to a winning
process that's what she did with that
weight loss says weight loss and
exercise system and it's worked to the
point everybody's going what did you do
I mean chick lost 65 pounds that's
noticeable hello
everybody's going what up what do you do
and then she tells him but then they
don't go do it uh-huh there you go see
right there it's exactly what I'm
talking about
less parrot doctor less parrot that is
going to be speaking at the Smart
Conference has a wonderful system on his
website that you
can take a marriage analysis called deep
love and you can take an analysis a
survey and fill it in and then it will
tell you the areas of your marriage that
are strongest in the areas of your
marriage that you need to work on and it
will give you exact steps to go work on
those now les is one of the best-known
voices in all of the marriage space and
as far as putting a survey together and
developing a system and the thing that
spits out suggestions he wrote a lot of
the programming for harmony so shut up
this guy he's the best in the world at
this so you can take that deep love
assessment and then read it all and go
yeah why aren't agreeing he shut up I
don't care what your opinion is you're
losing when you're losing it a space
don't give us your opinion about the
space it makes you look stupid
don't do that you're losing if you're
losing in a space don't have an opinion
it makes you look stupid
don't do that you do what someone who's
not losing says to do why is this hard
because we all have egos I'm amazed at
the number of broke people who have
strong opinions about my investing
advice is that not the dumbest but thing
you've ever heard you live in your
mother's basement and you write a blog
about how Dave Ramsey's wrong investment
advice is wrong
get a job son get out of your mother's
basement nobody cares what your opinion
is when you live in your mother's
basement about finances you're a broke
loser seriously think about this why do
we do this stuff it'd be like me having
an opinion about growing hair on top of
my head that would be dumb
I don't have any hair on top of my head
I'm not good at growing hair there for
me to have an opinion about that would
be stupid
it obviously whatever I'm doing there is
not working why would you follow me on
that you shouldn't find somebody that's
winning at something and submit yourself
to a proven process whether it's your
spiritual walk your marriage your
finances your physical condition your
parenting find somebody that's winning
and submit yourself with their process